hello and welcome to learning with
jagman x
today I'm going to be talking to you
about design terminology that will help
you communicate your ideas better
so if you are a designer or at least are
aspiring to be a designer then you might
have already heard that communication
skills are a necessity what's the point
in being able to dream up thousands of
design mechanics systems and other cool
ideas if you aren't then able to
communicate them to the rest of your
team or even to a publisher who might be
able to fund those ideas because
designers are often just seen as the
idea people which I guess is kind of
true but the best ones are the ones who
are able to directly and succinctly
explain how those ideas are going to
improve and experience and the clearest
way to do this is to use the correct
terminology to convey your message
almost four years ago I started working
as a designer within a triple A game
studio and it afforded me the chance to
work with my much much more experienced
designers and learn a lot about the way
they communicate with those around them
during these years I have collated a
list of the most useful terminology that
has helped me to communicate my design
ideas improvements or even my concerns
and this very list is what I would like
to share with you today so without
further Ado I will share with you my
list of super useful design terminology
affordances
affordances are simply put what an
object can do however this is only
revealed by the user taking the correct
possible actions so therefore it's up to
the designer to make sure that the
affordances are clear to be understood
by the user perceived affordances are
the affordances that the user perceives
that an object has if the designer has
done their job right then the perceived
affordances will line up with the true
affordances of the object and false
affordances are perceived affordances
that do not align with the object's True
affordances by either having a use that
was not intended or having no use at all
I'm going to use doors a lot this video
to give you examples of what I mean when
I'm talking about these design terms
because doors seem simple to design and
they are not trust me
if you know you know so the affordances
of a door is that a door can be opened
or closed pretty easy a perceived
affordance of a door would be that the
user sees that it has a handle and
therefore perceives that the door must
be pulled towards them to open a false
affordance of a door could be that the
user sees a key-sized hole underneath
the handle and perceives this door can
be locked with a key however this might
simply just be the design of the handle
and the door actually does not have any
locking capabilities it is a false
affordance when designing for games
however there are innate affordances
that players will expect that do not
necessarily align with real-world
experiences
for doors there is a rule of thumb that
usually they will open away from the
player for better ease of use signifiers
signifiers are specific elements of an
object that enhance its affordances
simply put
it shows what affordances something has
in our door example the signifier here
would be the handle as that is what the
users use to perceive what way the door
would open and also what action they
needed to take to open the door
this is a visual signifier as it's
something that the user sees to then be
able to perceive its affordances and
more simple examples of these would be
labels on jars or signs on roads to let
you know where to go in games we still
utilize this real world knowledge as it
keeps the environment familiar for the
player however the signifiers are
modified a little bit for the digital
platform for instance a door in a game
will often still have a door handle as
that is familiar to the player but we
will also need another signifier to show
them how to use the door and this is
often done with an on-screen button
prompt
Telegraph in game design the term
Telegraph can often be used alongside
the term signify because they both give
the user information about the object
however Telegraph is often used to give
advanced notice of a change to the
object rather than being intrinsic to
the object itself the term Telegraph
actually comes from Sports they use it
in martial arts to reveal what kind of
attack is coming next and it's also used
in games like chess where people try to
conceal what they are thinking so they
don't Telegraph to their opponent what
their next move is going to be and I can
relate to this because I do this when I
play battleships dad says my battleship
and history is me an example of this in
video games are wind-up animations to
Telegraph incoming attacks this gives
the player a chance to learn from them
and react to them as well
feedback
feedback is when the object reacts to a
user to let them know what action they
just took and lots of this time this
feedback can simply be the action
happening so if a user turns the handle
of a door and takes the action of either
pulling or pushing it to open the door
then the feedback would be for the door
to open if they took the correct action
and to stay closed if they took the
incorrect action however if the door
remains closed then how does this
feedback give information to the player
about why the door did not open if the
door remains closed a user can simply
look through the crack of the door to
see if it's locked or even give it a
shimmy and see if it has a bit of give
but in a video game players do not have
the same sensory information afforded to
them as users do in the real world so
the designers need to use a mix of
visuals and audio to help portray this
feedback lock doors for instance might
have a distinct locked noise or
sometimes even the player's character
might say something to them like I think
I need to find a key to open this door
feedback loops an extension of feedback
our feedback loops which are used to
either enhance or buffer changes within
your system there are actually feedback
loops all around you even now if you
decide to turn on your heating this
winter then that will cause a positive
feedback loop as your radiators will be
warming up but when they reach their
desired temperature the thermostat will
kick in and tell it to stop pumping out
Heat this is a negative feedback loop
and both negative and positive feedback
loops are needed to create balance in
games gameplay Loops are used to enhance
a player's gameplay experience by having
gameplay systems that are affected by
the player either negatively or
positively positive feedback loops
reinforce the current player experience
which allows the player to continue
either their successes or their failures
a famous example of positive feedback
loops is Call of Duty's killstreak
system this system basically gives perks
to players to enhance their success but
in turn this will also enhance the
failures of others negative feedback
loops however help to balance the
current player experience as they help
players who are struggling and hinder
players who are successful a famous
example of negative feedback loops in
games is Mario Kart's distribution
system which is weighted for the best
items to go to those who are further
back in the race this gives them more
chances to gain a blue shell which
specifically hinders the player in the
lead used well feedback loops keep the
game feeling fresh and adaptive while
also allowing it to be more accessible
to players of different skill levels as
the game can adapt its gameplay systems
to their playstyle rewarding those who
are skilled and also allowing them a bit
more challenge while helping those who
could be struggling
constraints constraints of rules that
are applied throughout the user
experience that either restraints or
enables that user constraints are really
important to allow the user to
understand the limits of the user
experience and therefore also allow them
to set their expectations and because of
this constraints are usually kept the
same throughout the whole experience in
video games these constraints can
manifest in many ways and the most
prominent example that I can think of is
full damage as a player myself I always
really like to play around trying to
find the limits of the full damage
before I see a death screen and although
as a rule of thumb it's always a really
good idea to keep your constraints
consistent throughout the experience to
keep in line with player expectations
games can sometimes allow a little bit
of Change by giving in-game item such as
upgrades or Buffs and designers
themselves must often understand their
own constraints when coming up with
designs and decision making constraints
are design limitations that designers
must work within the confines of however
these boundaries can often help to Aid
creativity as it gives designers
criteria that must be met and adapted to
and an obvious example of this is money
what really cool design idea can you
come up with within the confines of a
budget
constant
a constant is a rule that cannot be
changed and unlike constraints where
it's good practice to not change a
constraint constants are an ever-present
factor that can't be changed even if you
wanted it to gravity for example is a
constant it's something that's always
there and we can't change it but we work
within the boundaries of it in a game a
consonant can be the inability to see
beyond the screen it could be the need
for inputs or it could even be the
ability of the player themselves
States
objects and systems are made up of a
possible sequence of states and when
designing for an object it's really good
to understand what these possible States
could be for example a door could have
three possible States open closed and
locked
conditions conditions are rules that are
affected by user actions that meet
certain criteria that affect these
states for example the condition for a
door to be put into its open state will
be for the user to interact with it
however if the door is in a locked State
then the conditions will change so that
that same interaction will no longer be
able to open the door another action
will be needed
possibly unlocking death and damage are
common examples of conditions in video
games usually a player will have a
number that represents their health
but every time they get damaged this
number will get reduced now the
conditions for the death state to become
active will be if the number becomes
zero or less after being damaged
uniformity
uniformity is used to describe the need
for something to say consistent
throughout all types of an object and
this helps to make the object easily
identifiable to a user you often see
this in branding so that someone can see
an object and know exactly where it's
from but designers also use this to
build up perceived affordances within
users if all doors use uniformity to
show a panel to signify when a door
needs pushing and a handle to signify
when a door needs pulling there'd be so
much less confusion about what action a
user needs to take to open a door we've
all done it where you've pushed when it
was a poll or your pole when it was a
push it can be confusing at times games
use uniformity to help the player
understand the game world and roles
within it for example God of War uses
runes on pieces of the environment that
can be scaled climbed upon jumped off of
and Resident Evil uses the color yellow
on specific grapes that can be broken
and could contain loot
commonality commonality is quite similar
to uniformity however it's used more
throughout the development process to
explain the sharing of features or
attributes through different objects
where uniformity usually explains the
visual elements being shared commonality
usually explains the technical elements
being shared for example within a video
game you might have a wide array of
weapons that all might look quite
different but the most efficient way to
develop these weapons would be to ensure
that you had a commonality between the
setup of all of their shared features
such as melee bullet projectiles
reloading damage types to build your
games like this you might be interested
in looking into component based
designing
slow the term flow explains the intended
user experience when a user interacts
with an object from start to finish a
doors flow for example is for a user to
interact with it in a signified way
which allows the door to open then the
user can walk through to the other side
and it is up to them whether they would
like to close the door behind them in
video games however a doors design flow
is a lot more intricate as there are
many more factors to consider such as
whether a door can be locked or unlocked
what way it will open whether you have
NPCs and again that can interact with
the door if it's automatic or manual
here is an example of a really simple
door design flow that I wrote when
updating my indie game Perfection as you
can see writing out a flow graph can
really help you as a designer figure out
the flow of your designs as well as
catch any edge cases
Edge case
an edge case is a problem that occurs in
a very specific situation it's usually a
mild problem because of how specific it
is however it's always a really good
idea to try and anticipate where these
edge cases could be during the design
phase for example an edge case of an
audio speaker could be that at high
volumes the audio could distort
therefore lessening the overall quality
now some edge cases such as this one
might not be such an issue however some
of them would be worth addressing such
as if it's a specific system crash
exploit
exploits are potential or sometimes
specific flaws in a design that allows
the user to reach the outcome without
going through the intended flow for
example shaking a vending machine to get
to the yummy treats within the user
still gets a snack but they have missed
the vital part of having to insert money
first although I've used that as an
example but I'm pretty sure that only
works in the movies if you have done it
let me know in the comments maybe you
don't want people to know you've done
that actually
in game design the determination of what
is an exploit seems to differ but in my
experience I've seen many designers
design with exploits in mind for example
by creating gameplay systems and objects
within the world that hinder a player
but if used in a specific way can
actually help them as well a simple
example of this would be an exploding
red Barrel as players know to avoid them
because it could cause them damage
however they could also explode parts of
the environment nearby it exploiting the
area to the player's advantage while
also dealing damage to enemies nearby
and on the other spectrum of game
exploits are speedrunners which are
notorious for their exploitation skills
these players use glitches and bugs in
the game for example holes in a
collision to win the game in the
quickest way possible
salience
salience is an elegant word that
describes a part of the object's visual
design that's particularly notable if an
element seems to Garner the most
attention and jumps out from the
environment surrounding it then it's
Salient in game design especially level
design it's useful to think about this
in terms of where you need to lead the
player using interesting lighting or
notable environmental objects will
instantly draw player attention to that
location discoverability
discoverability is the degree of ease
that the user can find all of the
elements and features of a system when
they first encounter it the success of a
design usually depends on the amount of
discoverability that it has because
there's no point in coming up with a
really cool system or feature if a user
cannot discover its uses for themselves
keeping all of the terms that I have
described today in mind during the
design process will help you design
thoroughly and therefore enable you to
achieve a high level of discoverability
and that's it all of my most useful game
design terms congratulations for
reaching this far now you can go off and
tell the world your amazing design ideas
with your newfound communication skills
as a little disclaimer like a lot of the
human language a lot of these terms can
be used slightly differently by each
designer some designers have preferred
terms to others depending on their own
experience and specialisms however these
are the most common terms that I have
both heard in the workplace and read
about so I think they're the most widely
understood however if you think that you
know some that should be added in this
list but aren't then please do let us
know in the comments down below most of
these terms I actually learned from the
book The Design of Everyday things and I
have it here
this book
the Design of Everyday Things by Donald
A Norman this book was actually given to
me in the game Studio when I first
started out as a wee Diddy little game
designer so even though it is the Design
of Everyday things such as kettles and
doors it really taught me how to sync
like a designer it's a really insightful
book if you want to learn more about
design terminology as you can tell I've
gone off script a little bit now but I
did want to say if you wanted another
video of this that is specifically more
about game design terminology then also
do let me know in the comments and we
can share about things like weenies
because that's always a fun word to say
thank you so much if you reached this
far in the video it really means a lot
to me that you spend your time watching
my content I know it's been a while
since I made a Game Dev Style video so I
really hope you enjoyed this one I'm
currently working on a another music
track with my producer Jamie at Verizon
Productions and yes that will then
become Another music video made in a
game engine I also stream quite a bunch
on Twitch so if you want to watch me
play games talk about game design or
even join me on Monday mornings where I
do a Monday morning motivational stream
we talk about our weekly goals if that
sounds interesting to you then join me
on Twitch twitch.tv slash lagman X and
thank you so much to patreons I'll put
your name up on the screen now your
support really means so so much to me
and I always love chatting with you
especially in the Discord as well so
thank you very very much okay I think
that's enough from me have a lovely day
evening and I'll see you in the next
video bye